hello everyone and welcome to game
number three of Dalian masters 2018
match between voiceless oh and Ramesh
Babu pragna Nanda now before I get into
this game there is a quite quite an
alarming matter I have to discuss with
you yesterday I posted a story on
Instagram and it was supposed to be just
for fun I I posted a position from the
game
Russian news medina vs. all electronical
and I asked what moved it Nash Medina of
play in this position here I have it
here and I thought I thought like 99
percent of my subscribers should know
this game as its it is one of my
favourite games and it is a video that
has the most views on this channel some
some 1.7 million views so this is the
position and I asked there what move
didn't is Medina play here Queen
captures on f6 or Queen to h6
and I really thought that like at least
90 percent of of people should know this
but as you can see after a whole day of
you know answering this question the
final result is 55 percent answered
correctly Queen captures on f6 and 45
percent of you answered to Queen to h6
which is quite alarming so I really
think everyone should know this game
it's a phenomenal game as I did make a
video on it I will put a link in the
description below do check out this game
as it's quite outstanding it's not a
long video some eight minutes but if you
don't have eight minutes to spare I will
also put a link to chess Gamescom where
you can just you know check out the
moves of the game so that being said I
will ask this question once again after
like maybe maybe a week so I hope the
resulting answer will be like at least
90% but okay let's get back to our game
so for those of you who haven't seen a
couple of my previous videos here are
Wesley and Frog Oh looking very smooth
there and a lot of you may have missed
this game for for for a specific reason
but I'm sure you will enjoy it so let's
check it out Wesley has the white pieces
and he played
d4 we have Knight to f6 Bishop to f4 let
me just take care of that d5 Knight to
c3 and the bishop to f5 nice the b5
assault like we've seen in game number
one a voice League repeats the variation
which means because Wesley lost game
number one so he probably has an
improvement to game number one nice - a6
defending c7 alike in game 1 we have III
east 6 c4 so everything the same as in
game 1 and here if you remember probably
wind worship 3 7 but here he also has an
improvement he plays c6 kicking the
knight back Knight to c3 and nice to be
for now here Prabhu is already
threatening night to see to check and
there is only one good move to prevent
this we have rook to see one and here
comes Queen to a5 for those of you who
have perhaps only started to getting
into this a wonderful game of chess
maybe you're considering this move
Knight to c2 checked with the idea of
winning the rock this isn't this is well
almost never worth it because here you
will win the rook but it's not you who
is winning the rook it's actually your
opponent who is winning two pieces for
the rook so if row captures Bishop
captures Queen captures
you just lost two minor pieces for the
rook which is like almost never worth it
so until until you really know what when
it is it's worth it don't don't do this
so okay after rook c1 Queen to a5 a
bringing the Queen into the attack we
have a Queen to d2 and now comes D
captures on c4 it's interesting did
Wesley offer the a to point here really
well it's really not all that simple
after Knight captures rook to a-1 pins
denied okay but here comes the Bishop to
b4 so again you can't capture here
because Queen will capture the knight
chapters and then Bishop captures Queen
but after f3 let's say D captures on c4
and E for white will have an excellent
game he will be able to develop Bishop
captures on c4 Knight is coming he will
also be able to castle so not something
black really wants to do unless he's
like really prepared for this line and
wants to prove something but you know if
if not then better not you know touch
the pawn
if you're not sure if it's poisonous D
captors on c4 and Bishop captures on c4
we have Nightbeat 35 here Prague offers
a trade of pieces also attacking the
bishop on f4 so he wants to trade pieces
but he would very much enjoy grabbing
that Bishop on f4 so Bishop to e5 Wesley
gets her way Knight captures on c3 we
had Bishop captures on f6g captures pawn
captures and now rook to g8 g 3 and here
comes a bishop 283 so because of Wesley
avoided a trade of pieces there and he
decided well played creatively it's
actually Prague now who has a better
position he does have the bishop pair he
does have the same you open a file for
his rook on g8 the Queen is placed very
nicely on a5 and he can choose either he
will Castle queenside or he will leave
the King in the center and develop the
rook via loop to d8 so a very nice
position for Prague
rook to d1 gets the rock out of the way
rook to d8 here progress sites you will
not Castle queenside the engine prefers
castling queenside to this rook to b8
move but it's such a small preference
that it's you know if for a human is
basically a matter of taste
so rope to d8 we have f3 preparing e4 b5
now attacking the bishop and Bishop to
d3 we have before now and here comes the
shock characters on f5 first B captures
on c3 a nice in-between move Queen to c2
and now rook to b8 here you could
capture here with well of course now
with the point you don't want to triple
your pawns but maybe you can capture
with the Queen but here rook to b8 and
even better move by frog Oh
temporarily sacrificing the piece for a
very nice attack rook the b2 is coming
and now you have to do something either
black will get a free attack or you're
gonna save a piece and be up a piece
looks a bishop to e4 was played by
Wesley and it's the best move if you
retreat it to d3 you're gonna lose the
Queen after rook to be to the Queen had
doesn't really have anywhere to go
Queen to c1 and now you can win either
by c2 check or simply rook captures on a
- opening up a discovered attack from
the bishop to the Queen and after Queen
moves now C to check will win
queen so bishop three four definitely
the best move square for the bishop
rook to be to attacking the Queen and
here Queen really has nowhere to go if
Queen C 1 then white loses in the game
instantly but there is one move that
allows the Wesley to save the game and
that is Bishop captures on see sex with
Chuck King moves and now Queen to a four
because the bishop is now on c6 the
bishop is guarding the a four square and
the Queen now has an escape route Queen
captures an a4 Bishop captures Sunday 4
and C 2 now this is the position Prague
Prague had in mind and here there's
really nothing to do but to give back
the extra piece if you try to keep keep
the extra piece for example Roxy 1
getting through colored weight and rugby
one will win the game immediately if you
capture black we get the Queen and well
if you capture here then rook captures
King King King D to rook c8 is coming
and it's a completely winning position
for black a white can never develop the
knight the rook and it's it's only a
matter of time
so after this c2 move Wesley decides to
give back the piece we have a bunch of
characters on c2 rook captures on c2 and
now Knight to h3 Wesley managed to
activate the night and now the rope can
come into the game Bishop to b4 check
King f1 and now Rock G to c8 still
waiting with that rook captures an a2
you know better to improve the position
first rock to g1 and now comes Rock
captures on h2 nice to have to locking
that rook on the h2 square
rope to c2 now threatening to capture
the knight on f2 and now comes rope to
g2 rook captures King captures and now
while you could grab the the pawn now
it's even better to play a bunch of the
d2 going after d3 pawn and it's also a
very nice trap for Wesley if Wesley
tried to prevent this with something
like e 4 then Bishop e3 wins the game
immediately the knight is attacked twice
you do have to defend it and now you can
play whatever you want you can grab this
point you can grab this point for
example rook captures and after white
plays something like this to get the
point out of the way King d6
is coming there's no way to prevent this
pawn and then any any moment you'd like
you can simply capture an f2 and it's
game over simply exchange both the rook
and the bishop and push the a 5.2
victory
so after Bishop to d2 King to h3 we have
Bishop captures on e3 Knight to g4 now
attacking the bishop and Bishop to C 1
so the material is almost equal progress
a perform but it's a double death one
but still a better position we have d5
pawn captures rook captures and rook to
a2 now so grabbing the a to pawn and
here rook the c5 again you have to be
very careful your Bishop and c1 is under
attack if you move it like something
better up to a3 now the rook is no
longer guarding the a7 points so look to
c7 can easily win the pawn here and
there's a really no way to take
advantage of this so here Drago decided
to sacrifice a pawn he played h5 forcing
the rook to go back rope captures on h5
and now Bishop to b2 we had rook to c5
here comes the bishop to d4 attacking
the rook rope the c4 now attacking the
bishop and rook to d2 now Knight to h6
now attacking the f7 pawn so rook to c7
will be a threat so King to e6 not
allowing rope to c7 to come with check
we have King to g4 and now comes King d5
attacking the rook rook to a4 we have
Bishop to e3 attacking the knight on h6f
for blocking the bishop and now Bishop
back to b6 King to a5 and here we have
rocked the 3g for and now comes rope to
d4 here a very nice move by Prague Oh
either offering a trade of rooks or or
forcing the white rook to move back of
course you don't want to trade rooks
because then the a pawn would be too
powerful we have looked to a6 and it is
a really passive square for the rook but
it's really hard for for Prague to take
advantage of the passive rook Bishop to
c7 is played here here Prague offers
offers the a7 pawn but of course Wesley
will not capture it if Wesley captured
this then but rook captures on f4 would
be checkmate as and there is nowhere to
go
so after Bishop to c7 King captures on
f6
displayed we have rook captures on f4
with check King g7 and now basher back
to b6 still lock in the work on a6
we have g5 king to e6 and now comes rock
to a to rook to f3 preparing to me -
rocky - with rock III blocking so rocky
to his plate rook III again Wesley
cannot afford to exchange rooks because
then the a pawn will be too powerful
Rock - G - and now rock to f3 here rock
back to e2 check was played rook to e3
and here rock back to g3 and after rook
back to f3 they decided to agree to a
draw okay well progress up a pawn but
it's very hard to take advantage of it
for example if you wanna let's say
instead of this move start pushing your
passport then rubgy for simply not
allowing this point to go any further
and after Luke d3 preparing room d4 to
block block drugs defense of the a for
square you would simply check King moves
and now rook to a4 and after you block
this now comes Rock - a - and okay well
now you can push it Knight captures on
f7 now White has created a passed pawn
of his own so you you can start moving
your passed pawn but then white will get
a passed pawn of its own and since it's
it's pretty pretty far away to decide to
do something this rash in a rapid game
after this room g2 rook f3 was played by
Prado and they agreed to a draw so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
game number three ended in a draw so
first game went to Prague Game two when
- Wesley then this game was drawn and we
also have one more game and I'm probably
gonna show that game as well I would
like to thank Scott Adams Tony more
guitar a Julian showing a Sasha Marsha
and then Phelps for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
most likely with game number four of
Wesley versus Prabhu and do check out
the game management Dean of versus
Cherenkov it's it's a blast and after a
week when I repeat this question I would
really like to see at least 90% of you
answer correctly see you soon